we're flying to the chief's game in
Denver to try to see the biggest star of
all time the one everyone can't stop
talking about that's right we're on a
mission to find Paul Rudd or as you
might know him Scott Lang AKA Ant-Man
author of lookout for the little guy
since we're flying to Denver and back
all in the same day we didn't have any
time to spare so there was no time to
stop for anything okay we stopped for
breakfast it was pretty tasty but now
it's time to find Paul we were in a rush
so we headed straight to the stadium we
stopped at meow wolf and it was awesome
in case you don't know what meow is it's
a series of huge interactive art
installations and at the Denver one it
tells the story of a multiversal transit
station not too dissimilar from some of
the Multiverse story lines my man
Scott's been a part of anyways we made
it out just in time to get to the game
but it was so cold and snowy we weren't
really able to find him Paul if you see
this just know that meeting you would
fulfill all of
[Music]
my